it's a film of Oscar buzz written all
over it it was all over the Golden
Globes the shape of water won a Golden
Globe for Best Director Guillermo del
Toro directed it and the cast is
outstanding Sally Hawkins Michael
Shannon who's been on the show Octavia
Spencer and the man sitting to my right
the actor who we have loved for so many
years and the visitors Six Feet Under
and also yes Step Brothers good to see
you Richard Jenkins how are you great
rich good to be here as I mentioned yes
Step Brothers for a lot of people in
this audience is their version of the
shape of water that's Shakespeare
it was almost iambic pentameter one
point you're talking about dinosaurs I
think there might have been some time
before before we get to all of that in
this fantastic film and you're a great
role in it I want to hear this story so
you're on the set of the shape of water
and it's Game seven of the World Series
between the Indians and you you're a
Cubs fan all your lack of on my whole
life yeah I grew up in Illinois and been
a coach there my whole life but so we're
shooting a scene the last scene of the
movie in torrential rain you know with
rain machines not and the sound truck
has a little TV and they're got the game
live so I'm running back and forth to
the sound truck Cubs are up Cubs are
coming and all of a sudden they're tied
it's like what the comeback I can't we
have to this long shot we can't do it
the very end of the shot the producer
Myles Dale comes out with his phone okay
that's about to say cuz we're in the
21st century here yeah and he has this
phone but I have no because it's pouring
rain we can't have stuff on us and he's
got his phone and but it's on a delay
and and the ground ball to Chris Brian
makes the catch and his back foot slips
I don't even remember this but it just
slipped and I'm thinking he's gonna
throw in this day oh my god it's gonna
go yeah
and this the boom operator is hooked up
to the sound truck which has got it live
on and right before he throws it and I
see his foot slip the sound guy goes
Cubs win it was like because I knew it
was gonna be end awfully it was gonna
dab it off terribly and he was live and
I didn't have to wait for the delay
were you the only one on the set so
interested in people were congratulating
me like I made the play
congratulate yes I didn't hit I didn't
do anything sure I was the only Cubs fan
around but I can imagine again at least
even some people who might not be so
well versed in baseball or what have you
to know that you you know you'd been
waiting your whole damn life for this
sort of thing right I you know I on my
mother had a Cubs purse used to carry
around all the time as my mother would
watch the Cubs and my dad would turn it
off he gets so upset with him but my
mother loved the Cubs and when I was in
Little League see you know I'm old now
so I tell this story and I think is it
really true did it happen
the Cubs used to come to our banquet
come on in DeKalb Illinois and I was
maybe 11 12 this is back when in the
offseason they sold cars and they sold
insurance yeah I was no money in that
let him Ron Santo and Don Kessinger and
I think Jim Hickman came to my little
big banquet I had ties on they all spoke
in the camera and now this again as I I
think it happened but doesn't matter if
you remember Eddie Feiner the king in
his court sure
soft soft of course he was in town with
it giving an exhibition and they these
guys wanted to see if they could hit him
so Santo Kessinger and maybe Jim Hickman
or Glen Beckett I don't know what went
to the game took their coats off with
her ties on and tried to hit Eddy faint
did they know Ron Santo fell down as I
recall oh my god Doncaster they were
brutal I mean they were his day they
were laughing is Richard this sounds
like the natural where the Whammer gets
off the train tries to mount on three
pitches that's why I wonder if it's true
I mean I may have dreamt it but I really
believe I saw and I remember I remember
Santa Ron Santo taking his jacket off
leaving his tying white shirt on and he
kind of fell and got dirt all a free
shirt it's amazing the things that
you'll remember Richard Jenkins here on
the Rich Eisen show go ahead and ask
them a question you wanted to ask him go
ahead so you've been in how about like
50 movies there's lots of movies
have never won the World Series did you
at all consider calling out sick that
day
yeah will you just tell them I
understand it's the last scene of the
shape of water no but even just like
faking it
no because the Cubs had never won the
World Series so why would it change
[Music]
that's a great answer I thought you
would say well I'm not a professional
yeah that's why when his foot slipped I
thought oh my god I thought you were
just gonna say cuz there was all sorts
of rain machines that well the signal
went out just as his foot slip I would
have never worked again but other than
that it's right these Cubs these these
young guys on this Cubs team they had
then meant nothing to them yeah it did
they didn't know what they didn't know
and a hundred years of all this business
with the goat and all that craziness you
know didn't matter that's what part of
the reason why that much of the country
fell in love with him too
yeah these guys it was amazing Rizzo and
Bryant and all of those guys they're
gonna be there forever yeah it's evil
and you were in stealing home as well
that what was that experience like for
you what's fun it was great you know
Mark Harmon Jodie Foster he's a terrific
guy yeah I think it was the year he won
People magazine's sexiest man in the
world we were out to dinner one night
and we went to this restaurant he goes I
can't eat here I said why I said well
it's just good what mm-hmm he said you
have a room we could go and the guy said
yeah a room in the back so we went in
the back and I said what's the been a
five minutes later thirty people they
come on it'll meant to look at Mark
Harmon because he was mr. Sain elsewhere
or interesting elsewhere he was still a
Bruin quarterback and whatever really
good get but it's a neat movie what what
what's your favorite sports movie cuz to
me you know sports movies that like
stealing home always have like that that
center of it with a heartbeat yeah yeah
it's not really about the sport correct
yet right which one would you say then
gosh you got me now I did it tell me
something you like oh okay well Hoosiers
is my number Oh Hoosiers is great who
Gene Hackman is the greatest coach in
the easies great it's fantastic I I
always find myself Richard Jenkins again
the shape of water here in the Rich
Eisen show I always find myself doing
what I do for a living that the the
stuff and Hoosiers where you can measure
the rim to the floor and the foul line
to the end line
it still works like for this weekend
with these playoff games that we're
talking about right now that Case Keenum
I just spoke to his all-pro safety the
Vikings he's never played in a playoff
game before but it's it's still three
it's still three free or yeah right it's
a hundred yards long okay so ask me what
my favorite sportsman what's your
favorite sports Mosers can we cut up
this very good I do love Hoosiers I
anything Gene Hackman does is Hoosiers
great Bull Durham is a lot of people
mentioned that I'm I wouldn't mention
rocky but we had it confirmed by none
other than Carl Weathers himself that
it's a love story it's a love movie it's
not really a sports movie now rocky okay
now if you agree with something like
that I get it okay
the shape of water in theaters near you
right now when you take on a role with a
script like this where it's essentially
a love story between a woman and a sea
creature beast and you play a character
who is involved in this because you're
the next-door neighbor who's equally as
lonely as the young lady when you read
this sort of stuff well what do you
think when you get a script like this
Richard I wanted to do it immediately
this is what you do yeah this is how you
know you love it you almost sent me an
email and said I'd never met him and he
said I want you to play Giles I hope you
love it as much as I do and I read it
and I sent him an email back the next
day said I think I do
but when you you know you love it when
you're reading this character and you're
turning the page and you're saying
please no die please do because that
it's it's right I
you read something and you either it
speaks to you or it doesn't it's about
as simple as that there's no other
reason you just read you go I I think I
could find something in there that are
you sometimes you're reading you go I
hate there's so many guys who could do
this better than me or this doesn't
speak to me and I knew immediately when
I read that mm-hmm
did you had to do it now when you're
shooting the scenes with the the
creature I don't know and we could call
it was there really somebody in a set
like that yeah Doug Jones in a rubber
suit basically he's he's entombed it's
like being buried alive except you can
move around you are covered everything
is covered except your eyes and your
nose and your mouth you're entombed in
this right and in fact one of the extras
that did a stunt double thing for him
they put him in a suit and I think was
it a dancer I'm not sure but he got so
close to phobic he threw up in the suit
oh my god it's a hole you got to be a
certain kind of dude to do this I bet
and he's in it for 14 15 hours a day
right I know and you just met him over
there Mike del 2fo he's in a he's in a
Mike del Tufo suit every day we put him
to be zip him up in that scale entombed
he's right there every single that's
what we call him every single day and I
appreciate you doing that every day for
that when you got a good story from the
set of stepbrothers
will ferrell john c reilly and he was
there anything in particular about that
film and um well that my first wasn't
was my first day but it was close I
didn't know Adam McKay the directors
hell sure and he's a wonderful so we're
shooting a scene and himself friend goes
off and I hear a time safe whose phone
is that
and he starts screaming hmm I told you
never ever to let your cellphone's onto
the set it's it you scream I mean oh my
god this is gonna be a long shoot and he
comes into the room who was it who was
it
nobody says anything turns around he
goes never ever happen again I'll call
you back
[Music]
[Laughter]
this shoot was gonna be and you know it
was the dinosaur speech that you talked
about I was sitting there at the
Catalina Wine Mixer
and Adam McKay said to me go tell will
and John that you wanted to be a
dinosaur when you were young I said what
are you talking he said you know just go
tell them you want
I said Adam what are you talking about
so it was not scripted I just came home
it said go tell them so like whatever
and I started talking and both of them
kept saying to me that's just not
possible what are you talking and I came
back home that won't be in the movie and
Adams it oh yes it was I mean the two of
them Adam I mean will and John are so
quick they just did just you just you
can't keep up yeah it is so quick I mean
it's great and I mean which film that I
mean you've been in a whole genre of
them from the witches of eastwick I mean
I've got a whole bunch here Silverado
sea of love Jack Reacher I mean which
genre do you enjoy the most the ones
that the checks cash no I like that the
fact is I've been lucky enough to do all
different kinds of films you know and
that's feet under is will endure you
were terrific and thank you that was one
of those things where I was just
supposed to do the pilot and and then
Alan Ball said you want we'd like to
have you come back because he said it
occurs to me that once your father dies
you don't stop thinking about him so I
said sure so I I came and went it was
great five years unbelievable
and do you have a bucket list director
that you'd want to work with but yeah I
don't really think that way you know I
mean there's it's I don't have any like
parts I won't want to play or I just
kind of that one of the things I love
about being an actor is you never know
what's around the corner
like this shape of water I get an email
one day boom yeah and it's like there it
is and now here we are with it it's just
it doesn't happen very often
it's it's um I don't even know how a
movie gets made it when you see how many
people make decisions about things and
how much money it takes and if you
wonder how anything ever gets done but
once in a while you hit a really good
one you know and this story reminds me I
got to check my spam folder a lot more
often than I did you never know well I
don't think mine was a spam okay well I
mean you know at at del Toro or whatever
it might be you know at had whacked out
ideas dot-com I mean that line I don't
know how his mind works it's it's like
nobody else
yeah and he's hysterically funny he's
like Bill Belichick in a way where you
think maybe you never know it could be
that funny okay he said to me well but
the first day I worked with him we did a
scene and I said I'm not happy here mom
on it I'm gonna change it up my Jason
okay fine so I did it a different way
and I said so do you want to maybe shoot
it again to cover it in case this
doesn't work and that he's Richard we
are not that kind of men we make a
decision we stick with it
Tim knows later he goes I think we'll
shoot it again you just told the story
it's a great story if you're like he
came up to you and say okay go up to
Michael Shannon and you say you always
wanted to be a dinosaur Michael
oh man Michael Shannon oh yeah he's he's
great your greatness it's a super movie
people should go see it thank you for
coming in here Richard leasure you bet
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience